- So, you play Satan.
(Kelly chuckles)
So, what kind of...
- Yeah, Satan.
- What does one do for
research for that role?
(audience chuckles)
- Well, I...
- Do you read the Bible or...
(Kelly chuckles)
- No, I didn't read, no, I did read that.
I did look at the demonic book
that the, that we referenced this book.
So, I did a deep dive,
because there's like all these
different words for Satan.
So, I looked up...
- Like Lucifer, all of that.
- A DDD, demonic deep dive.
- Oh.
- [Kelly] I think there's
a lot of them, yep.
- There is a lot, right.
And so, but I don't know,
if you're playing somebody that's so evil.
I don't think evil people
think they're evil,
or they're bad, right?
They think, kind of think they're good.
And so...
- I think they're called
narcissists, but yeah.
(audience and Kelly laughs)
- Yes.
- We see them all the time.
- They're just out and about.
(Kelly chuckles)
- And so, I don't know.
I wanted her to be a little bit
like Tracy Flick in "Election".
And I think she desperately
wants like friends.
I think she's obsessed with,
I think she really feels like she's going
to get Melissa on her side.
She's like, she's like, "I could see it".
And I think she just really wants to be,
like picked for the team.
And I don't think she ever is.
So, I just...
- And then burn you alive.
- And then burn you alive and she does it.
She really turns on you.
- But with a smile.
- Oh, yeah.
- She'll turn on you really fast.
- Oh, yeah, that was a great movie.
Yeah, can I get you something?
Yeah, I'm going to burn you alive.
(Kelly chuckles)
Light the couch on fire and then...
- [Kelly] I just think that'd be a more,
like a more fun role to
play, someone so crazy.
- It's so fun and these
guys let you do anything.
They're so fun to work for,
because don't like, they let you try.
- Yeah.
- Anything, right?
(man chuckles)
- We don't have a plan going in.
(Kelly laughs)
So, we're just like...
Do something, no, I'm kidding.